try this last one nice to watch Sal's
face
go ahead record his drum kit just [ __ ]
oh wow he's on the sandbox yeah 501 the
spa [ __ ] you better answer quick oh my
God look at it ready oh I got a business
thank you very first we bring in a
backup ass Benji stay in the same spot
all time yeah I don't really
Richard move your hands a little bit I
don't mind I'm hitting on the double
into the jungle that's the best part
sounding of the drum boys and well you
know that one Thailand ransom now it was
rocket queen believe it or not I had I
tell you what one last song on the drums
you get it right I'll get you to take it
stupendous yeah but Anthony has to hold
my foreskin right there that happened
how does not happen if you hold his for
hold many things before that that's the
cowbell and I want with your mouth are
where it is if you get this one right
we're going to send you right to the con
let me face it come on go ahead really
huh
go ahead Richard try come on you brung
you got it oh my really thank you
all right everybody goes to the concert
thank you when I was playing mr.
brownstone my thumb witnesses crack I
gotta go wash my hands
yeah lick it lick it I dare you to lick
your thumb
the song is mr. Brown aye mr. Brown Hall
[Music]